We spend a lot of time in relationships
pointing out what's wrong with the other
person and insisting on our blamelessness. We imagine that's a good strategy
for getting what we want and for being
happy in a couple, but that's nonsense.
Next time you feel strong enough that
you can, for a moment,
stop insisting you're always right, try a
different tack. Out of the blue
say: "sorry I'm so anxious"
"sorry I lose my temper", "sorry I don't
listen enough",
"sorry I'm too preoccupied", "sorry I both
want you close and push you away",
"sorry I'm not always balanced, sane or mature". You think that might weaken you, make you
hostage to the partner's vengeance.
It never does. Everything always gets
better from that point.
Give it a try. Sorry I'm so crazy.